what is the threats of artificial
intelligence to education
well there are I think there are many
more opportunities unrivaled
opportunities to give all young people
regardless of the schools they're in and
the parts of the country they're in and
indeed the learning difficulties that
they might have extraordinary
opportunities for enrichment for
real-time assessment uh and and marking
to free up teachers to spend much more
time with young people because a lot of
the heavy lifting will be done by the
machines but they're also very real
risks
um risks of obviously plagiarism uh
risks that all the difficult parts will
be taken over by the technology which is
only in its infancy at the moment the
rate of change is going to be uh
incredible over the next five and ten
years as we've already seen
and and fear of deep fakes of uh of of
moral uh damage uh to young people which
is already quite considerable with
social media uh will be magnified
because of the uh the extraordinary pace
of change and schools teachers parents
we're all bewildered
it's interesting to use that word are
you taught there about the use of deep
fakes and is that something that you're
seeing in your schools amongst young
people like it's almost feels to me like
another tool of bullying that people
could use
yeah I mean uh it is uh extremely
invidious uh and uh dangerous how uh
manipulating uh the technology can be
because it will understand I mean as we
know uh when we're shopping uh when
we're looking on the internet the
personalization of the material that
comes to us will become far far more
sophisticated and young people are young
they can't negotiate the world very well
and uh so the opportunity for them to be
manipulated bullied uh brought into
practices uh drugs all the rest of it um
it is very worrying to parents very
worrying to schools so what we're saying
is look
um the edtech companies
um have a lot of profit motive they're
making enormous amounts of money out of
the technology
um that we can't make them go away we
have to ensure that we provide uh
parents schools uh teachers with really
good information about what is wholesome
uh stimulating good uh Ai and what uh
people should be aware of because
government uh who really have caught up
in the last few months but they're still
behind the curve and they never quite
understand what happens in schools
Parliament doing some good work but they
take a lot of time to to to come out
with their statutes and recommendations
we have to take it into our own hands
schools to ensure that human
intelligence is at the very heart of
schools artificial intelligence will
never take over from humans as long as
we put human intelligence first and
don't just try teaching young people
with tests and exams in a way that is
giving them the skills that the
algorithms will always be better as
Martha Lane Fox was talking about we
need the skills in this country and
skills are the interpersonal skills the
human skill the the problem solving the
entrepreneurial skills uh which uh which
are not being sufficiently done in
schools because we're just narrowing
everything down to exams so I think that
there is a lot here that is enormously
exciting but we have to get ahead of it
in the interests of the children and the
many uh not the few parents teachers
you mentioned the interview with Martha
Lane Fox um she was also very strongly
saying that the government shouldn't be
looking at International students to try
and get net migration figures down
what's your view on that
well I think universities are doing I
mean I would do wouldn't I used to be a
vice Chancellor I I are doing a superb
job uh government have failed to provide
the leadership of the sector uh
universities should be right at the very
heart of that drive for productivity
that Martha was talking about
um but if uh without a more benign
attitude from government if Government
stays obsessed by
um but by numbers
of overseas students who so enrich this
country and the economy in Britain's
relations with the world it's it's just
um looking at the wrong thing government
really isn't smart about the leadership
of Education
or school education
they're obsessed by narrow data whether
immigration numbers or whether exam
results they really don't get what
education is all about and they
certainly don't get AI sufficiently yet
that's really interesting to hear your
thoughts on it um I'm interested as the
head of um Epson College because there
has been a bit of a debate about private
schools particularly among the labor
party kirstama saying that he would
abolish the charitable status of private
schools levy VAT on fees what's your
reaction to that
well
um I think that um that this initiative
here uh that we're talking about is
cross-sector between its jointly led by
Epsom and uh by a multi-academy trust
born academy is the example of
collaborative work between independent
and state schools which I think is the
model for the future personally I don't
think that getting rid of uh Independent
Schools or putting so much Financial
squeeze on them will actually help at
State schools I think working together
side by side is the way forward and I
think that that is what we'll see
because if Independent Schools have to
close they simply aren't the places in
the state schools to take all those
young people so let's have a a much more
imaginative policy from government uh
and a much more forward-thinking policy
for government
and let's see both both sides of that
education divide working much more
closely together that's always what I
wanted to see you think there's a
genuine risk of independent schools
closing then
yeah and I think it's going to be
particularly those uh which are serving
areas uh where there is lesser income uh
whether these are already lower where
the um the margins are much tighter and
where those schools are serving
um really serving their communities and
giving
parents another choice I think it's good
that we don't have a uniform education
system that there is choice and
diversity within it I think that is the
strength of the British education system
it's why overall and historically we've
had such a good education system so
um you know who will see look Labor uh
out of power uh before 1945 before 1960
Ford before 1997 is always made
threatening noises about wanting to get
rid of Independent Schools and of course
I understand that argument but when it
gets into power and the practicalities
bite in
um that they do other things and that
they go off in other areas I think much
better to try and raise the standards of
all state schools not the least by
understanding government understanding
what AI is and how it can give a top
quality education to all and to have
both sectors working together I think
that's a better way myself
and just finally talked a bit about the
choice that parents have um Rachel
Reeves a cello Chancellor said she
wouldn't send her children to private
school because she wants them in her
words to see the world as it is do you
think she's got a point
yeah I I think
um that a lot of Labor ministers
historically have always sent their
children to Independent Schools there
are some superlative
State schools I think the best of State
schools are better than Independent
Schools but I think also that's a little
bit unfair to some of the incredibly
imaginative Independent Schools which
are doing things uh to stretch and give
their young people opportunities which
the more uh which there simply isn't the
the time often in a state school to do
but look that's her choice she's
exercising her choice
um good for her and
personally we send our children at
different times to both state and to
Independent Schools we have a fantastic
State sector which has got better and
better